nutzen ausgangs beschränkungen überhaupt
etwas am sonntag wurde es für
deutschland entschieden ausgang
beschränkungen für ganz deutschland fast
so streng wie in italien frankreich
spanien und belgien eine britische
studie prognostiziert jetzt die zeit
nach dem ausbruch und erwartet die
gezielte verbreitung des virus klicks um
science-fiction er gibt es spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
activity glocke nur dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
mit jedem weiteren tag wissen wir ein
bisschen mehr über das verhalten des
infektionserreger skoff zwei jedes noch
so kleine detail hilft forschern dabei
mithilfe von simulationen und modellen
in die zukunft zu schauen und eine
einschätzung zu den künftigen
entwicklungen ist wichtig um notwendige
und sinnvolle maßnahmen zu ergreifen
stichwort stay home oder auch stay at
home und es an dieser stelle einmal mehr
zu betonen es geht um leben und tod also
bleibt zu hause doch von der hand zu
weisen ist auch nicht dass wir als
gesellschaft dadurch enorm eingeschränkt
werden die politik hatte verkündet dass
der samstag entscheidend war wie
verhalten wir deutschen uns und halten
wir uns an den appell unsere sozialen
kontakte weitgehend einzuschränken
in einigen bundesländern gab es ja schon
sperren sowohl bayern als auch das
saarland hatten ausgangs beschränkungen
im kampf gegen korona verhängt jetzt
haben wir also aus beschränkungen für
ganz deutschland
aber keine ausgangssperre dazu der
polizei gewerkschaftssprecher aus berlin
benjamin landreau eine ausgangssperre
wäre ein drastischer einschnitt in die
grundrechte der menschen allerdings sind
anscheinend immer noch nicht alle
sensibilisiert dass das corona virus
eine große gefahr sein kann deshalb
scheint eine ausgangssperre
als nächster schritt nicht mehr
unwahrscheinlich doch wie wichtig und
wie sinnvoll sind solche maßnahmen
schulschließungen home office ausgangs
beschränkungen und so weiter
mittlerweile gibt es erste analysen wie
lange und wie streng solche maßnahmen
eingehalten werden müssen um das
schlimmste zu verhindern dazu schreibt
die gesellschaft für epidemiologie auf
ihrer website diese modelle eignen sich
um aktuelle empfehlungen zur
infektionskontrolle abzuleiten um
vorhersagen treffen zu können ist es in
der aktuellen situation notwendig
annahmen über das verhalten des
infektionserreger zu treffen
diese basieren auf daten des bisher
beobachteten infektionsgeschehen und
werden
besser einschätzbar je länger die
pandemie anhält ein britisches
forschungsteam hat jetzt analysiert
welche auswirkungen verschiedene
maßnahmen auf die ausbreitung in den usa
und großbritannien haben könnten wie
also wirkten sich verschiedene maßnahmen
auf die krankenhaus einlieferung und die
infektionsraten aus wenn sie entweder
einzeln oder kombiniert stattfinden
die erste option beinhaltet dass
einzelne fälle isoliert werden also
infizierte und auch die entsprechenden
haushalte vollständig isoliert werden
eine weitere einzelmaßnahme bezieht sich
auf die schließung von universitäten und
schulen das social distance in wurde als
eine weitere option genauer analysiert
damit ist gemeint dass nicht nur
bestimmte risikogruppen sondern auch die
gesamte bevölkerung weniger soziale
kontakte pflegt die modelle machen ein
ergebnis ganz deutlich wenn keine dieser
maßnahmen ergriffen wird verläuft die
verbreitung des virus exponentiell und
das gesundheitssystem wird komplett
überlastet auch die durchführung einer
einzelmaßnahme kann diesen worst case
fall nicht verhindern genauso wenig wie
kombinationen aus verschiedenen
maßnahmen selbst die isolation von
verdachtsfällen und die kontakt
reduzierung von sehr alten menschen und
die quarantäne von infizierten reicht
den modellen zufolge nicht aus um die
ausbreitung einzudämmen
denn sogar dann noch würden
intensivbetten für patientinnen und
patienten mit schweren krankheitsverlauf
fehlen die modelle zeigen aber auch dass
die kombination bestimmter maßnahmen
zunächst erfolg versprechen scheint wenn
beispielsweise infizierte patienten
patienten isoliert würden und schulen
und unis geschlossen würden und ein
gewisses social dissing in der
bevölkerung eingehalten würde könnte die
verlaufs kurve unter die
kapazitätsgrenze fallen auf der einen
seite ist das natürlich eine erfreuliche
nachricht auf der anderen seite würde
uns dieses langfristig gesehen kein
stück weiter bringen denn fachleute
weltweit sind sich einig dass etwa 70
prozent der menschen eine immunität
haben müssen gegen das virus damit es
sich nicht immer zu weiter verbreiten
kann doch solch eine hohe immunität rate
ist nicht gegeben und wird auch nicht
erreicht wenn alle auf distanz
zueinander gehen heißt also im klartext
das ganze problem werde nur aufgeschoben
und nicht aufgehoben
waldflächen weg auf die entwicklung wird
langsamer die krankenhäuser haben eine
chance mit dem ansturm fertig zu werden
aber was dann
sobald
die maßnahmen wie beispielsweise auch
eine komplette ausgangssperre wieder
aufgehoben würden könnten die
infektionszahlen erneut in die höhe
schießen und niemand von uns kann
derzeit mit hundertprozentiger
sicherheit sagen dass wir in der zeit
die wir durch die maßnahmen gewinnen
würden auch sicher zu lösungen kommen
was ich damit meine
maßnahmen wie ausgangssperren schenken
uns zeit zeit um medikamente zu
entwickeln an impfstoffen zum forschen
und intensivbetten zu beschaffen doch
diese zeit reicht sicher nicht um dann
eine extrem riesige kurve abzufangen die
intensiv medizin wird also nur solange
nicht überlastet wie wir zuhause bleiben
gehen wir dann wieder irgendwann raus
ins café zum sport ins büro oder in die
schulen und universitäten sind wir dem
virus genau so schutzlos ausgeliefert
wie vor einem lock down wenn man das
ganze zu ende denken müsste dieser also
so lange anhalten bis ein impfstoff
gefunden ist oder ein medikament das
einen tödlichen verlauf verhindert doch
das wird nach meinung von
forschungsteams noch einige monate
dauern
die folgen für die wirtschaft wären
fatal und auch für die gesundheit der
menschen wäre eine solch lange isolation
fatal
dadurch würden wir uns zwar von virus
schützen doch dieser ausnahmezustand mit
isolation und quarantäne geht an den
psyche gut denkbar dass damit
beispielsweise stressbedingte
immunerkrankungen herzerkrankungen und
depressionen zu nehmen würden und was
folgt daraus um den kampf gegen das
corona virus zu gewinnen müsste also zum
einen gewährleistet werden dass die
gesundheitssysteme nicht überlastet
werden und zudem eine gewisse
immunisierung der bevölkerung vonstatten
geht die britischen fachleute haben
dafür ein lösungsvorschlag gezielte
verbreitung des virus demnach müssten
die fallzahlen gesteuert werden und zwar
wellenförmig was damit konkret gemeint
ist so schön distance in beispielsweise
durch die schließung von schulen und
universitäten müsste immer mal wieder
verhängt und dann wieder aufgehoben
werden und zwar so dass immer
ausreichend intensivbetten zur verfügung
stehen und die anzahl der todesfälle
reduziert werden kann in der anderen
phase dann in der das öffentliche leben
wieder weitestgehend normal abläuft
würden sich teile der bevölkerung
infizieren und damit immun werden
so könnte sich nach und nach die so
genannte herdenimmunität einstellen ein
wichtiges instrument im kampf gegen
während die infektionszahlen am anfang
bestimmten darüber wie lange die erste
internet
schon anhalten muss sobald die zahlen
dann sinken könnten die maßnahmen
zurückgefahren werden bis die zahl der
infizierten wieder ansteigt sprich durch
die gezielte lockerung der maßnahmen
wird das virus verbreitet aber immer nur
so weit dass das gesundheitssystem nicht
überlastet und damit könnte man die
sterberate wahrscheinlich unter 1
prozent halten aber es müssten eben
menschen sterben so lange bis ein
medikament oder ein impfstoff gefunden
ist nur so besteht die möglichkeit dass
menschen immun personal aus dem
medizinischen bereich beispielsweise
welches dann das system weiter
supporting kann auch hier ist klar dass
sich die gesellschaft einschränken
müsste dennoch gäbe es pausen für uns
und wir würden stück für stück an
immunität gewinnen aber jetzt gilt
erstmals stay home stay at home und
flecken und hier habe ich gestern
herausgefunden dass sich die
exponentielle kurve der fallzahlen in
der letzten woche also nicht am
wochenende sondern schon davor etwas
abgeflacht hat hier geht es zum video
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren nun
dann bekommt ihr sehr spannende
zusatzinfos wie übrigens nur hier auf
max hansen fiction seit anfang januar
also bis dann bleibt dran